the strongest one there is the largest
lawyer in the courtroom if the hulk and
she-hulk threw down which green goliath
would come out on top
as we've witnessed through multiple mcu
outings raw strength does not always
determine a winner in battle still it
doesn't hurt fans are given an idea of
how strong she-hulk is relative to
regular hulk when the two powerhouses go
toe-to-toe during the first episode of
she-hulk attorney at law bruce banner in
his professor hulk form tries to
convince his cousin that her new powers
should be used for the good of the world
but jennifer isn't interested in
becoming the superhero an argument
ensues and when jennifer loses her
temper she transforms into she-hulk and
throws the first punch initiating her
first super-powered throwdown both hulks
land some big blows during this fight
with professor hulk launching his cousin
through the air and she-hulk breaking
the avengers glasses which only serves
to make him even angrier it's
entertaining but it doesn't give any
definitive answers in terms of strength
she-hulk is still new to the whole hulk
thing and professor hulk is clearly
holding back yet the scene does show
that she'll can at least hold her own
against the avenger matching him blow
for blow hurting him more than once she
isn't afraid to play a little dirty
stomping on his foot and even running
him over with a car
sometimes it takes nimbleness speed and
balance to gain the upper hand in a
fight unfortunately for hulk he's
lacking in this department a brute beast
bruce banner's alter ego has
historically relied entirely on his
ability to throw the most brutal punches
and hulk
smash
though he has been known to jump from
building to building in the past hulk is
about as far from spider-man as a hero
can be shield does not gain the same
lumbering muscle-bound physique as her
cousin when she transforms her
physicality does improve dramatically
however which makes for better reflexes
and balance
as shown during the first episode of
she-hulk attorney of law she naturally
becomes a skilled acrobat quickly
outdoing her powerful relative when the
two square up prepared to battle walters
appears much more poised and nimbler
than the bulky and lumbering hulk while
banner is a lot faster since his two
personalities merge to become professor
hulk he's nowhere near as nimble as
she-hulk
witch hulk has won the most fights one
would think that this would be no
contest considering bruce banner has
been smashing his way through the mcu
since 2008. unfortunately hulk's track
record in the mcu is not quite as good
as one would expect in fact audiences
have witnessed the big green monster
lose more often than not hulk was
convincingly defeated by thanos in
avengers infinity war and before that he
got a beat down courtesy of tony stark
and his hulkbuster suit in avengers age
of ultron there's also his near loss to
the titular god of thunder in thor
ragnarok to consider hulk hasn't really
won a super human battle since throwing
loki around like a ragdoll in 2012's the
avengers she-hulk is still a rookie
contender who doesn't seem interested in
fighting anyone outside of the courtroom
still in her first real test against
titania and she-hulk attorney-at-law she
wins easily if it weren't for the
largely overlooked early mcu entry the
incredible hulk starring edward norton
in the lead role instead of mark ruffalo
the hulks would have near equal records
there is no argument that bruce banner
is one of the most intelligent marvel
characters a renowned scientist he
casually mentions to thor that he has
seven phds during thor ragnarok beyond
his education banner has been an
integral partner to tony stark during
multiple avengers movies assisting in
the construction of ultron and the time
machine utilized in avengers endgame
it's not just his post-transformation
muscles that are huge he arguably has
the biggest brain in the whole mcu well
if he could do that he could achieve
heavy ion fusion at any reactor on the
planet finally someone who speaks
english
is that what just happened however as
jennifer walters states early in
she-hulk attorney-of-law banner is not
the only genius in the family a highly
competent lawyer walters may not have
the credentials that her cousin boasts
but she knows the law like the back of
her big green hand and can more than
hold her own in a courtroom walters
consistently takes clever jabs at banner
and his alter ego proving that her wit
is a match for his as her mcu series
proves she hulk often comes out on top
when arguing with her cousin
a significant factor that deserves
consideration is who a combatant has in
their corner iron man would have never
been thanos without the help of the
avengers spider-man could not have
defeated norman osborne without
spider-man and even a hulk needs backup
once in a while when it comes to hulk vs
she-hulk it's doubtful that any mcu
heroes will put themselves in the middle
of a family dispute however a good ally
is always worth having in your corner in
the comics she-hulk easily wins the
friendship round being the ally and
resident attorney of many marvel heroes
including the fantastic four and captain
marvel meanwhile hulk has been on the
wrong side of so many heroes that the
illuminati exiled him from earth it's
still early in she-hulk's mcu career but
it should be easy for her to make some
superhero friends quickly it's already
confirmed that characters such as wong
and daredevil will appear in she-hulk
attorney at law meanwhile the mcu
version of hulk has been a staple of the
avengers lineup since the inaugural film
in 2012.
while trying to decide who would win in
a fight between she-hulk and hulk it's
worth looking at how a battle between
jennifer walters and bruce banner would
pan out hulk in human form is not much
of a combatant unlike other original
avengers banner never gained hand-tan
combat training and is often portrayed
as a little timid sure he impressively
defeated kul obsidian during avengers
infinity war but that fight would not
have lasted very long without tony
stark's hulkbuster outfit keeping things
equal jennifer walters is not a highly
trained combatant she's a successful
lawyer dedicated to her career still
she's much more confident than her meek
scientist cousin based on the
relationship showcased in she-hulk's
attorney of law we suspect that walters
regularly came out on top during
childhood familial roughhousing and if
the two were to fight without their
hulking abilities there's reason to
believe that walters would take the win
if the influx of superhero shows and
movies has proven anything it's that you
need someone on your super team who
packs a mighty punch in the comics a
version of the hulk has often been part
of the avengers lineup in fact he was
part of the very first lineup however
deciding who to recruit becomes
difficult when choosing between a raging
giant beast and a composed powerhouse in
the case of hulk he's as strong as they
come and can take on some of the biggest
challenges unfortunately his penchant
for flying off the handle and causing
more destruction than good can become
more of a burden than anything else
conversely she-hulk is a woman who keeps
her composure most of the time at least
and she can deliver blows of near equal
strength to her powerful cousin plus
jennifer walters has the added bonus of
being an established lawyer while it's
always nice to have a physicist around
having someone who can take care of
legal business in your squad certainly
sounds more promising
both hulk and she-hulk have been part of
the marvel collection for decades
she-hulk first appeared in 1980 with her
self-titled comic book her relation to
bruce banner helped her quickly befriend
many superheroes and she soon became a
member of teams like the fantastic four
the avengers and the defenders she hulk
became a fan favorite thanks to her
comedy stylings that often featured her
breaking the fourth wall long before
deadpool made it cool and in the early
90s there was almost a she-hulk movie
starring brigitte nielsen as well as a
couple of proposed television shows
alternatively hulk was first introduced
in 1962
and has remained a shining part of the
marvel roster since the character has
become one of the most popular
superheroes globally while the word hulk
predates the marvel comics it has become
part of the english lexicon for someone
losing control of their temper or
hulking out
spawning multiple comic titles tv shows
movies video games and plenty of other
merchandise the original comic series
the incredible hulk has hundreds of
issues while she-hulk has some clout she
will always be a variant of the original
and may never reach the same level of
popularity in a fight between she-hulk
and hulk this is the ultimate question
what is more powerful pure anger or
self-control it's this factor that
differentiates the two combatants hulk
is a synonym for rage it is his anger
that not only triggers his monstrous
transformation but fuels him during
battle not often explored in the mcu
hulk's strength is basically limitless
as the angrier he is the stronger he
gets you know sorry i just got so angry
all the time all goes always angry on
the other hand she hulk has similar
capabilities and her rage can cause her
to become more dangerous however the
fact that jennifer walters has more
control over her alter ego arguably
makes her a more formidable warrior as
is pointed out during the first episode
of she-hulk attorney at law being a
woman probably puts walter's leagues
ahead of banner in the self-control
department
the triggers are anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing all right then where hulk
can fly off the handle and become an
unstoppable beast with near unparalleled
strength she-hulk has the patience and
capability to remain at the steering
wheel of course she can also become a
total rage monster but she has more
choice in the matter being able to
maintain a cool head in a fight against
her rash and unruly cousin might just be
the deciding factor
in arguably one of the best toe-to-toe
throwdowns in the history of the mcu is
hulk vs thanos in avengers infinity war
the fight highlighted just how powerful
the purple foe was while causing such
damage to hulk's ego that it took years
for the mean green fighting machine to
recuperate that's why bruce banner had
to use the hulkbuster armor to fight
club obsidian later in the movie the
hulk refused to surface but what if it
had been she-hulk aboard that asgardian
ship as opposed to her cousin would the
result have been any different as seen
in avengers end game female heroes have
fared much better than their male
counterparts when facing thanos scarlet
witch and captain marvel both held their
own against the mad titan just like her
cousin she-hulk would have no doubt
managed to get in some strong blows
using the element of surprise
unfortunately thanos is just too
powerful to be defeated by any one
avenger alone walters would have likely
suffered the same dreadful beating the
hulk took although she may have been
aware enough to avoid the one-on-one
fight altogether the real question
should be would she hulk have been
capable of donning the infinity gauntlet
and performing the same snap her cousin
did bringing back half of the universe's
occupants she has the blood of the hulk
pumping through her veins so there's
nothing to say that she couldn't
withstand such a thing
hulk vs she-hulk would no doubt be a
battle for the ages a real drop down
drag out of a fight that nobody would
forget in a hurry the hits and
destruction would probably resemble the
intense bout between hulk and thor and
thor ragnarok however it's safe to say
that this fight would be much more
personal whatever caused these
combatants to throw blows would no
longer matter in the heat of the moment
as each would want to prove that they
are the strongest hulk there is she-hulk
would use her wits her speed and her
mobility to gain a strategic advantage
over her enormous cousin her more agile
frame would allow her to dodge the
hulk's powerful but easily telegraphed
attacks still it only takes one of those
blows to land and the longer the fight
went on the angrier and therefore
stronger the hulk would become while his
blows would be slower and fewer they
would land
much harder and on top of that bruce
banner's alter ego surely remembers the
embarrassment served to him at the hands
of thanos the hulk would not want to
lose another big fight especially to his
newcomer cousin as impressive as she
hulk is she would have a hard time
keeping the hulk down
you